hello everybody welcome back to css3 and
30 days today is day number 20 and we
are gonna be making some random animated
pyramid let me show you what's going on
here so I needed an idea for a project
to make and I was starting to run out of
inspiration and I thought what can we
make that's interesting
possibly practical and exercises some
css3 chops and the best I could come up
with in this particular moment was an
animated triangle so here it is on your
journey to css3 mastery spend at least
20 minutes learning how to code a
triangle okay so let me show you before
before you skip this video and go do
something better with your time we have
a little triangle here and when you
hover over the triangle watch what
happens it's a lot more interesting than
what you see on the screen so far here
we go so check it out when you hover
over this triangle it creates a bigger
triangle with two other layers and then
text appears and the colors change so
it's actually kind of interesting and
it's super easy to make and it is
practical so it did check off all the
boxes and the way I might think of how
you might display this is if you were if
you had a piece of text or maybe you
offer to service let's say you're a web
designer and you you're building a
portfolio website and you wanted to
display the services you offer this
could say you know I'm hiding the text
so this could say services and then when
you hover over services it splits down
and shows the services that you create
that could be images as well if you want
it to display maybe like you know
different layers of a project if you had
like the financial final project in like
the top part of the triangle and then
like the wireframes and then you know
then the sketch below I don't know just
come up with random ideas here but maybe
you have some thoughts on how you might
use this and it's simply three elements
that that when you hover over them they
just animate down and appear the
interesting that's happening here is
that they're actually these elements are
actually three rectangles and I'm not
using
orders to create a triangle like we did
in a previous lesson just a couple days
ago I'm actually clipping the entire
element so this whole thing is wrapped
in an element called triangle and
triangle is clipped to a custom shape
that I created of a triangle now let me
show you in the code editor what is
going on so you know what I'm talking
about so go ahead and download 20
animated pyramid and fire it up and your
code editor and let's get started here
in index I'm going to show you the
mark-up looks simply like this div with
the class of triangle wrapping three
individual divs with the class of top
mid and bottom and then text within each
of the dibs that's it now what we're
going to do in our sandbox is simply
style those up clip it and transition it
it's really quite simple so let's just
get started here in the sandbox we're
gonna get started and we're just going
to style up the triangle triangles gonna
have a position of a relative height of
320 pixels that is the total height of
the triangle when it's done and and I'm
going to leave the clip path for now
we're gonna start with just rectangles
and we'll do the shape after so you know
what's going on triangle and then div so
we're selecting the divs within the
triangle and those are the three
individual lives background red
width 100% height 100 pixels we'll start
with the bare bones here we're gonna go
margin:0 auto and color white for the
text just so you can see everything
let's give them a little space just so
you can see a margin:0 auto and then ten
pixels on the bottom just for now so you
can see there we go with three three red
triangles now let this shape is not only
a rectangle but can sometimes be a
triangle let's tighten up the text a
little bit we're gonna say line height
100 line height 100 pixels so it's
vertically centered text-align:center
font size 0.8 m if we save that refresh
it so now we have top mid and bottom so
we have the three rectangles let me show
you what
happens when I'm asked the entire
element with a clip path so now watch
this is where magic comes in so we're
gonna say up in triangle clip path we're
gonna do polygon and here's that work so
we did have a lesson on creating custom
shapes so if you wanna understand
creating custom shapes using clip paths
and then you'll understand how these
coordinates work but let's start here so
we're gonna have three comma separated
couples of values so let me show you how
this works so we have 50% and 0 so if I
leave it at that let's see what happens
you can't see anything because we need
other coordinates so comma separate the
next two values 20% and 100% save that
see what happens still can't see
anything ok and now we're gonna do one
more 80% and 100% save that let's see
what happens now there's your triangle
the end result of the shape you see outs
mask so you can only see what's within
this window now if I change these values
you can customize the shape so if I said
like 50% there it looks like this you
know 10% it's actually got a longer left
side so if I were to say 0 this might
help you understand so that's the zero
percent mark on the x-axis yes and then
if I move that over 20% it's actually
going in 20 percent and then 100 percent
can be changed that to like 80 percent
it's actually now it's on the y-axis so
on the vertical axis the y-axis if I'm
if I'm not mistaken and so now it's 80
percent down from the top but if I want
it 100 percent down from the top it's
going to give me that perfect shape you
can have it any shape you really want
you can make it really wonky look in
shape like that if you want it's kind of
neat but I'm just going for a perfect
triangle which is 50 percent in from the
top left and 0 so
seeing on the zero up here that on the
y-axis and then you got 20% a in and
then you got 100% down and then 80% in
and 100% down creates the triangle
beauty love it now let's hide those to
the mid and bottom shapes rectangles you
can call them polygons and hide them up
at the top and then show them on hover
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to position:absolute the Triangle
div we're gonna say top zero we're also
going to hide the text so the color of
the text is gonna be red and we're gonna
remove that margin Auto ten it's just
gonna be margin:0 auto so there we go
save that now you can only see that
triangle so now we're in the right place
but when we hover nothing happens
because we're not telling it to do
anything so what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna say down here triangle hover
so on hover of the triangle of the Tri
ang the word triangle is versatile and
can also be pronounced tree Onge div
color white so all the colors of all the
divs army white and now all the the mid
and the bottom are going to be separate
positions so so all we need to do is
move the position of the of those
elements separately I don't want to have
them both be like you know top 100
pixels because what's gonna happen is
they're all just gonna move down to
there it's is really really weird so we
only want the middle and the bottom ones
to move so now we're gonna say triangle
hover and then the class of mid so we're
selecting mid we're gonna move it down
see if I'm moving on 100 pixels and see
what happens and let's change the
background while we're happening while
we're here to green so let's see what
happens so you see mid and still the top
but it's actually the bottom one is
hiding up there because the zet index so
we're actually gonna fix this really
quickly so the reason why i'm what i'm
going to do now is
autumn is is is here we can see it
within this clip path and mid is
actually working there's no gap there
we'll fix that but I want to fix the Zed
index of the top so let's actually go
here before the hovers so we're gonna
say just top Zed index 1 that should
just put it in front of everything so
top is the one that you always see so
that when it animates the top is always
in the front when the other ones slide
out behind it rather than the other ones
sliding out in front of it which would
look just a little off ok and now let's
see where was I let's go back to our
triangle hover mid and move it down 110
pixels because I want that gap in
between them like that cool ok and now
the other thing we need to do is I'm
gonna copy this and I'm gonna paste it
change it to bottom now we need to move
it down 220 pixels because we're going
down another 100 pixels change the color
to blue save that refresh hover now your
triangle appears but it doesn't look
very exciting because it's just
appearing and that's not actually
doesn't have any meaning to the to the
you know the functionality and it's just
weird it's quite off-putting so all we
have to do now is actually under the
triangle div style say transition so
it's not a true animation it's actually
just a transition we're gonna transition
all of the things that can be
transitioned so position color
background you know Heights anything
that we change will transition with an
ease at 0.6 seconds save that refresh
now try so
there we go Alex looks good
and that's it now let me just show you
actually why I did this top set index 1
I'm gonna take that out and show you
when I hover now without that you see
how they're the color these ones are
coming from the top they're coming from
in front of the element maybe I did a
really slow like 6 seconds you'd see it
watch see how its bottom and mid they're
coming out from in front of top I don't
actually want that I want it to slide
out from see I want it to slide out from
behind so by having that Zed index and
let's do the six seconds again it looks
more like this they slide up from an
under like that that's a bit more of
what I want and maybe what I want to do
is actually give mid is that it Nick's
in front of bottom so it doesn't so
bottom doesn't slide out in front of mid
ok so let's say mid we'll just go like
this mid it gets a Zed index of one and
top gets as that index of 2 save that
now watch
there we go now bottom slides behind mid
mid sides behind top that's exactly what
we're looking for let's go back to our
0.6 second transition now try it that
looks clean there we go
and that's it that's that's it for
today's animated pyramid project now the
way you might use this is totally up to
you depending on your project on your
website maybe it's a portfolio thing and
you're displaying information there's
lots of interesting things you could do
you can use different shapes you don't
have to use a triangle you can use a
circle you can have more elements that
slide out there's lots of different
ideas that you can do so maybe that gave
you some ideas maybe that kind of made
you think of a few different things
either way you got to spend ten or
fifteen minutes with me making an
animated triangle so hope you're having
a great day and I'll see you tomorrow in
game number 21
[Music]